قتال في السماء بخطوره عاليه جدا الولايات
المتحده قالت انها فقدت طائره مسيره من
طراز ام كيو 9 بعد ان اصابت مقاتله روسيه
من طراز سوخوي 27 مروحه مسيره الامريكيه
ما تسبب بتحطمها في البحر الاسود في اول
حادث منذ الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
مقاتلتين روسيتين بمضايقه مسيره الامريكيه
في المجال الجوي الدولي
القيتالوقود عليها وكانتا تطيران على
مسافه قريبه جدا مسافه اعتبرت خطيره
المسؤولون الامريكيون وصفوا الاصطدام
بالانتهاك الصارخ للقانون الدولي هذا
الحديث يدل على نقص في الكفاءه ويعكس
تصرفات غير امنه وغير مسؤوله ستستمر
طائرات الامريكيه والحليفه بالعمل في
المجال الجوي الدولي وندع الروس الى
التصرف بشكل احترافي وامن روسيا نفت عمليه
الاصطدام معترفه بان المسيره فقدت السيطره
بسبب المناورات موسكو اعربت مرارا عن
استيائها من تحقيق طائرات الاستطلاع
الامريكيه بالقرب من شبه جزيره القرم الذي
استحوذت عليه بشكل فرديا عام 2014 علق
مسؤولون في واشنطن وفي حلف شمال الاطلسي
على اعتراض الروس لهذه المسيرات بانها
شائعه وتعكس افعالا متهوره وخطيره من
الطيارين الروس الغزو الروسي ودعم حلف
الناتو لاوكرانيا زاد المخاوف من مواجهه
مباشره بين القوى النوويه لكن
الدبلوماسيين من النيتو اكدوا انهم لا
يتوقعون ان يتسبب هذا الحادث بتصعيد او
مواجهه اخرى